foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Super Bowl champ with the Ravens now the
University of Alabama head coach former
NFL analyst the University of Alabama at
Birmingham Trent Dilfer joins us on
behalf of our good friends at Panini
America
how are you Trent
good Dan how about yourself I'm doing
okay you got your Super Bowl your
miniature Super Bowl trophy there over
your left shoulder
so many yeah yeah does everybody get one
of those
no I bashadi bought this for me as I
exited after the one year in Baltimore
so wait that was your Parting Gift he
gave you a miniature Super Bowl trophy
yeah nice he's really gracious uh it was
actually before then
um my wife was gonna get me one and and
Steve jumped in and and made sure that
the Ravens did it for me how big is your
Super Bowl ring
uh you don't wear it very often I work
during recruiting uh recruiting the kids
like it it's big it's a it's a big old
sucker not as big as the ones they do
now
um but it's a big old flashy thing and
and the the recruits love taking
pictures with it when we had them on
campus but see what I think that they
should do is do a school ring you know
like a school ring size that you can
wear where it's not gaudy where you come
in Michael Strahan had the story he told
Eli he wanted a 10 table ring and he
like oh what is that you can see it 10
tables away and it's just too big you
can't wear it out
I agree I I like your idea the little
like school one or like the high school
state championship size yeah and then
they should give everybody like the real
like I think this is 60 the actual size
uh they should give all the players like
a 80 85 size like you go by if you're in
Denver's airport and you go by Elway
Steakhouse he's somehow got like 95
replica in the window it's it's pretty
cool I think every player would
appreciate that give me the three
quarterbacks two quarterbacks for like
they changed the the position
in the modern era that's a good one uh I
think Elway
um in that 83 draft So Physical right
that the talent was
um ungodly to a certain degree uh um
golly I think far you know I don't think
far gets enough credit uh somehow he he
gets dismissed from like the greatest of
all time conversations I I know I saw it
live you know getting my butt kicked by
him every year while I was in Tampa
during those three MVP runs he he
redefined the position to a certain
degree he was like a combination of
Elway Fran Tarkington uh Warren Moon
like he was all wrapped up into one guy
which was pretty incredible
um I think Lamar Jackson I think this
there's like four or five of them right
now uh that are so Dynamic such Dynamic
athletes and also great passers
um we saw this I'll give you a quick
story about 10 years ago through the
Elite 11 we started noticing a real
Trend where it wasn't just the the
coach's kid that was playing quarterback
it was the biggest baddest dude on
campus in high school like you'd go to a
high school in Georgia or wherever and
you'd ask the coach like who's the best
athlete at the school and they'd say oh
no doubt it's this guy and that guy was
the quarterback now you're starting to
see that come true in the NFL you know I
probably started with Cam Newton Lamar
um Mahomes Josh Allen you know these
guys are redefining how the position is
played and now it's equal decision
making accuracy precision with just like
this crazy ass horsepower too that makes
them so Dynamic but also I look at
Peyton Manning's impact on the game
yeah it might be more important than
Brady's impact on the game of you know
obviously the results with Tom but but
Peyton changed everything at the line of
scrimmage you know he's seeing what you
got now I get to you know change I mean
we hadn't seen anything like that before
had we
well I agree with you I but I don't
think Jim Kelly gets enough credit but
let's go back to Jim Kelly because he
actually was doing that you know I mean
it's like Jim was I went hunting with
Jim last year and and I've known Jim
forever but to hear him talk about and
he was not saying no they don't give me
enough credit he was just talking about
the complexity of what they did at the
line of scrimmage now he was also
praising Peyton for taking it a whole
another level but yes you're right kind
of that Jim Kelly started it and then
Peyton poured gasoline on it where it
was like okay we're gonna call whatever
we want and Peyton's Gonna Get Us in the
right protection the right uh Run game
the right route combination uh and
basically was an extension of the
offensive coordinator taking the snaps
yeah that's a great point I forget about
Jim Kelly in the gun you know where he's
pulling out the plays but I I you know
Peyton talked about like Zach Thomas I
said you know there had to be somebody
who was equal to you on the other side
he said yeah Zach Thomas drove me crazy
he said I call it out and Zach would say
look look out for the run and then I go
damn you know he's he's got me there how
frustrating must that be when they know
what you're doing
it's the worst you know it's the worst
when you think you're tricking them but
they're tricking you like they know
what's coming before the ball's now it's
funny you mentioned Zach Thomas I get
asked all the time with the two hardest
defenses I played against and they were
they're happy at the same time it was
that Miami Dolphins defense was Zach
Thomas's the middle linebacker and
Madison was one corner I can't remember
who the other Corner was but everything
looked exactly the same on every snap
until the ball was snapped as the ball
was snapped they played like 12
different things and then Green Bay at
the same time uh with Reggie and the Roy
Butler in that group you know it was one
Reggie when he decided to play he was
just you literally couldn't block him
nobody could uh and they had other great
players I think LeRoy Butler is one of
the all-time underrated defensive
players the least I played against
um and their ability those two defenses
were just vicious was it Patrick certain
would he have been with Miami back then
I don't want to get myself in trouble
yeah I think it was but I don't want to
get myself in trouble I'm getting sold I
forget everything Dan we're talking to
uh Trent Dilfer won a Super Bowl with
Ravens do you ever feel like that you
have to apologize because you won a
Super Bowl and everybody talks about
well the defense like like well somebody
had to play quarterback like you know
even Trent Dilfer won a Super Bowl I
mean it's not fair to somebody who had a
prolonged NFL career but that defense
was so good
yeah and there's some truth to it like
I've owned that like uh I I don't think
I've ever once gotten my feathers in a
ruffle when people say that you know I
was part of the team not the reason we
won the Super Bowl I would absolutely
agree with that okay I do think I was
the right quarterback for that team in
that moment uh and my teammates say that
which is the most affirming thing
um but yeah I didn't play very well that
year I played pretty darn good early on
when I took over for four or five weeks
I battled an injury I played terribly at
the last two regular season games
um
and then the playoffs you know the
playoffs we knew who we were it was just
a matter of literally it was true when
people say all I had to do was follow
the game that's a reality the reality
was to play the game in such a
conservative way that you didn't add any
risk uh to it because we knew a team was
weren't going to score more than 10
points ever against us so and I don't I
don't get my feathers in a row in a
Ruffles over that you know I don't get
defensive over that because there's a
lot of truth to it yeah
um and and my teammates have been so
great Dan like over the years those
Baltimore Ravens teammates have gone out
of their way
um to defend me when when people uh want
to tear me down on that stuff and you
know that's that's important when you're
when your teammates do that for you I'm
wondering about this with uh you know
now you're coaching in college at UAB
how much of your job is coaching how
much of it is kind of cultivating uh a
business nil and collect I mean mean
yeah this is more than it feels like
college coaching is tougher than
coaching in the NFL
I don't know I haven't been a head coach
in the NFL I have a lot of dear friends
that are so I don't want to make that
comparison you're definitely a CEO
you're not a coach you're not a you're
not a whistle Roger that coach very
often uh you get to do that and those
are the
so far those are the most fun days you
know when you actually get to interact
with players and and Coach ball
um but I at the bulk of this job is is
kind of CEO type stuff there's a
business aspect to it you mentioned it
with collectives and nil
um there's a team building there's
coaching coaches I think that's the
thing that doesn't get talked about
enough is you have to hire great people
um but then you got to coach them up
um to make sure we're all speaking the
same language uh you gotta Empower them
you got to create a culture is a word
that's overused but I think it paints a
picture that everybody in everybody's
head yeah yeah I create an environment
uh where people are are going the same
direction
um they feel it's energizing to come to
work
um when when we do have adversity
there's people around you to help you
get through it so yeah it's a lot more
other stuff than we'll run you back and
crew socks on going out there and doing
bag drills how do you poach somebody
without poaching them
like the t word that everybody's doing
and using yeah tampering yeah
yeah
I think what we've tried to do is just
create a really good Viber on our
program you know they can reach out to
you uh they can get in the portal and
and contact you
um you know really it's about creating
an atmosphere around your building and a
Persona around your program uh where
it's welcoming and you want and you
gotta and you gotta say Hey you know I
think Prime does a great job with this
on Twitter even you know like hey this
is what we're looking for if you're part
of this come join us we don't do it on
Twitter with the head coach tweets but
we're trying to do the same thing like
hey here's what we're building here's
what we're about uh if that fires you up
you know you know where we're at you
know I think Prime started this thing
like hey I'm not hard to get to I'm not
hard to reach you know where we're at I
think that's what's going on but the
reality of is we've had a couple poached
from us uh we know it's happening uh we
know they're talking to these other
programs before they're in the portal
and it's just the reality of where we're
at in this industry and and you got to
live with it what's the craziest ask
from a recruit
you know I've had any crazy outrageous
one so far you know we don't have you
know SEC money here and I think
everybody knows that but we did have a
couple walk in and it was their
motivation was definitely to get paid I
actually think they thought like I was
going to pay him with my NFL money like
literally that sort of felt like like yo
coach it's not legal though Trent that's
not legal I know okay but I'm saying it
felt that way like it felt like this kid
was like he knows we're not you know in
the SEC he knows we're not the Big Ten
he knows you know we don't have some
collective an eight million dollar
Collective but I kind of feel like this
kid wants me to tap into my own pockets
and like pay him with out of my own
that was not a very long decision let me
tell you that
um you're working with our good buddies
at Panini America the exclusive Trading
Card partner of the NFL what are you
doing with them uh this week and next
week
yeah they're the best man I've been with
them like hash I think it's eight years
now
um doing weekly stuff when you know when
I was in college coach coaching college
football I was doing a lot of videos and
stuff but the coolest thing I get to is
this Panini Super Bowl kid reporter and
I think it was 1600 kids no sorry 160
000 kids registered for this kid
reporter initiative uh and our boy miles
won it this year and and he gets to go
to the front of the line of media night
Monday night and ask all the superstars
questions he'll come up with the bummer
of this when they win is they have to
hang out with me for the whole night
um but uh I'll kind of Coach them up on
what questions asked and how to how to
get in the conversation with Mahomes or
Kelsey or Jalen whoever it is and uh kid
will get to ask the player a question
and do a lot of cool stuff so it's been
an amazing relationship it's it's one of
the more fun things I get to do over the
course of the year and I don't have to
stay the whole week at the Super Bowl so
while you're going to bed at eight I'll
be back in Birmingham going to bed at 7
30. how many times did you face Brady
ah
there wasn't that many
um
a couple times I think is all did you
think anything like if if I would have
said that guy is going to be the
greatest quarterback of all time
what would you have said do you think in
that moment
I wouldn't have believed it in the early
years you know pain was the same listen
a lot of young guys right I mean
finding your way
um some of them do some like me don't
fully find it uh but there's about I
don't know about year six or seven is
when you know because you're watching
crossover tape I think where NFL players
have the greatest appreciation for the
players is when you're watching
crossover tape because what is crossover
tape so we're playing we're playing the
Colts and the Colts played the Patriots
week before so you're watching Patriot
stuff right so you're always watching
the defense to get ready for the
defenses quarterbacks you're always
watching the other quarterback play
against that defense and I probably
watched Brady crossover stuff let's say
15 times and you're just like wow how do
you see that how do you see it that
quick wow he changed that protection wow
what a perfect throw man I didn't think
about you know using my eyes that way
and getting back to the other side and
you just kind of gained an appreciation
for the Nuance of what he does so well I
I really think that's the thing is now
that he's retired now we're gonna have
probably what two months of talking
about this to get ratings up for all
your shows talk about Brady every day I
think the one thing that's going to come
out as you talk to players what made him
so great is the Nuance of how he played
the game he did these little Nuance
things that always put his team in a
position to win to to win that play to
win that series to win that game
um it's that's why I think a lot of fans
can't go oh he's the best of all time
outside the Super Bowl rings they don't
see the Magic in what made him wasn't
the arm wasn't the feet wasn't the
stature wasn't the athleticism it was
the Nuance of how I played the game and
I think a lot of young great
quarterbacks now will go and although
they're probably better athletes and Tom
they'll talk about Peyton and Tom
especially those two of how much they
learned from those two watching them
play these little parts of the game that
aren't talked about very much great to
talk to you uh good luck with uh UAB
certainly Panini and uh nice to catch up
again thank you Trent
thanks Dan good seeing you man it's uh
Trent Dilfer won a Super Bowl with the
Ravens now the head coach of the
University at Alabama at Birmingham and
joining us on behalf of Panini America